pilar on the page it's been around since
2001 yeah on the page has been around
since 2001 I have a writer studio in Los
Angeles where I teach live classes and I
teach them on first draft rewrite pitch
TV some story analysis you know just
whatever I think that a writer needs in
the moment and also I have a podcast
called on the page we've been doing it
for I don't know seven or eight years
weekly podcast with writers and
producers anybody who can talk script
and how did you get into doing this how
did I get into doing this it's kind of a
sideways move a friend had asked me to
read a script for her for a company she
was working at I found out you could get
paid for doing that huh and I ended up
sending my samples to Amblin
entertainment at the time which was
Steven Spielberg's company and I got
hired as a reader and I kind of learned
on the job reading not only for Amblin
but also DreamWorks when they became
DreamWorks and a number of other
companies and then I ended up teaching
based on what I was learning from
reading scripts as and seeing how people
were responding to them what was working
and what wasn't working I tried to
translate those into tools and those
classes became popular became a book
stuff like that well we're here at story
Expo 2015 and we're getting you in
between classes and so forgive me if I'm
a little rushed here I just wanted to
find your take on this right now I'm
reading a Joyce Carol Oates book the
faith of a writer which is sort of about
her life and she talks about the writers
sort of isolation and some of the things
that are a little bit darker that some
of these books don't always cover one of
the things she says is the artist is
born damned and struggles through his or
her life to achieve an ever elusive
redemption by way of their art wow wow
hot cider I product that the artist is
born damned is very interesting to me
because I think that some people can
feel that they've been damned by
creativity that there is this need to
express something and they are sort of
in a personal jail until they can get it
out
and I think that that might be what
she's going for there is to talk about
this fact that it's not that an artist
creates because they want to make money
they create because they have to and and
and as far as that personal Redemption I
think it's more that idea of sort of a
personal release but I think she's
certainly onto something everybody's a
little damned and they're better people
for it teresting I like that should a
screenwriter have a plan B should a
screenwriter have a plan B huh I guess
look on a practical level I guess every
artist should have a way that they can
make money but not as the that that plan
that says well I'm going to give up
eventually and then I should do this I
think they're it's fine to have a job
that you love that supports the art that
you love and I think what you'll find
two is that they often go hand in hand
you know you can bring your writing to a
day job and you can bring the
experiences from your life and day job
and family into your writing so it these
things don't have to compete
you